collective action
we will work with like-minded allies to
ramp up lethal aid to ukraine at scale
providing kit
to president zielinski in in the
quantity and with the quality that he
needs
to defend his country
from its bullying neighbor
today i've announced that we in the uk
will send an additional six thousand
missiles and provide twenty five million
pounds in unrestricted funding for
ukraine's armed forces more than
doubling the lethal aid we've provided
to date
we're bolstering our support for the
nato countries on the front line
sending a new deployment of uk troops to
bulgaria
on top of doubling our troops both in
poland and in estonia
this is just the beginning
we must support a free and democratic
ukraine
in the long term this is a fellow
european democracy
fighting a war of national defense
nato and g7 leaders were also united
today in our determination to continue
turning the screws on the kremlin's war
machine including by weaning ourselves
off russian oil and gas and reshaping
global energy security
the uk has already hit
over over a thousand russian individuals
and entities in our toughest ever
sanctions and the foreign secretary
has announced 65 new sanctions against
russian banks weapons manufacturers and
oligarchs just this morning
i also discussed the humanitarian
response with our allies and partners
today as we continue to see huge numbers
of ukrainians flee their homes
and the message
that president putin can take from
today's extraordinary meeting of nato
and the g7 is this
ukraine
is not alone
we stand
with the people
of kiev of mario paul of la viv
and donetsk
and
as president zielinski has said himself
the people of ukraine will prevail
and putin
must fail and he will fail
thank you all very much and i'm going to
take
a few questions from
as many of you as i as i can though we
have to rush for a for a plane uh let's
go to nick beak of the bbc nick
thank you prime minister you say that
you're sending the the quality and
quantity of weapons that ukraine uh
deserves and needs but it was clear from
what president zielenski was saying to
you and other world leaders that he
would like more so first of all are you
comfortable with the level of weapons
you're sending collectively
and secondly
how uncomfortable does it make you feel
that by rolling out a no-fly zone by
ruling out
nato troops on the ground in ukraine and
by refusing to give any sort of
indication of red lines that really the
only end to this is when president putin
decides he's had enough
thanks very much nick and you you're
right to put your finger on the the
agony that everybody feels in this in
this group uh all western countries the
whole of nato uh g7
about our uh inability to to do more to
help given the constraints we face and i
think it's fair to say that uh there
isn't a a western uh democracy that's
currently contemplating putting putting
boots on the ground in ukraine and we've
got to be we've got to be clear about
that nor is there a a country that is uh
willing to enforce a no-fly zone in the
way that uh you we would so like to but
unfortunately it does mean uh it uh
air-to-ground attacks on russian air
defenses and it does mean uh taking down
a russian fast jets and asking the raf
uh to do that that's not something that
uh any country here is contemplating
what we are doing is steadily ratcheting
up uh the uh the the movement of of
lethal but defensive weaponry uh to uh
to ukraine and that is growing in volume
the whole time and uh what the americans
are doing and what the what they have
done is really quite extraordinary
already in the uk is proud of of what
we've contributed i'll go to uh sam
coats of skype
thank you prime minister sanchez
um president zielinski interestingly
didn't repeat his call for us uh no-fly
zone when he addressed nato leaders
instead he was very very specific he
wants tanks and jets
our nato members
are is the united kingdom going to give
him tanks and jets and if not why not
uh thanks sam he did he did indeed uh
call for for tanks and there's a there's
a particular reason for that to what uh
what president zielenski wants is to try
to uh relieve mario paul uh and and to
he and to help uh the the thousands of
ukrainian fighters uh in the city uh to
to that end he does need armor as he
sees it uh we're looking at what we can
do to help but i've got to tell you uh
logistically at the moment it looks very
difficult for both with armor and with
uh with jets uh
we're very conscious of what he's asking
for at the moment uh we're looking at
the the the equipment that we think is
uh more immediately valuable is uh is
uh uh
missiles
that will enable the ukrainians to
protect themselves against bombardment
from the air
but also to deal with the uh the grad
rocket launchers uh the uh the the
russian heavy artillery uh that is doing
such uh death and dealing such death and
destruction in the cities and there i
think if we can uh really help them uh
that would be extremely valuable because
they need protection from that
absolutely merciless uh onslaught from
uh from artillery and from and from the
rocket launchers
uh
uh james makes itb
uh prime minister you've also spoken
about weaning uh europe off russian oil
and gas there'll be discussion tonight
that you won't be part of the european
council
is europe doing enough are the germans
doing enough what will britain do to
help
other countries who rely more on russian
oil and gas to wean themselves off it
thanks james it look and i i just want
to say that this is easier for some
countries than it is for for others and
everybody can can see that and uh
clearly the dependency in uh in germany
and in italy is is is very strong uh and
there are many other european countries
that depend on on russian gas but what
they're all doing
is moving uh to extricate themselves
from that position and to
avoid being in a blackmailed by by
vladimir putin and i think that uh what
olaf schultz has done the steps that
they're taking i think it's it's heroic
and i i applaud what germany is doing
they set themselves uh
deadlines to move away from oil and gas
i i don't think it'll be easy uh and the
italians are doing the same i don't
think it'll be easy for them but it's
the right thing to do uh in the in the
in the long term in the medium term and
we will help uh of course and one of the
one of the ways that i think we should
all work together is in the sharing and
the uh development of of alternative uh
provision not least wind power i mean
the the baltic countries for instance uh
heavily dependent on uh on gas but they
have a fantastic future
as generators of clean uh renewable
energy we want to help that we have we
have a lot of experience of it
uh jason great daily mail
thanks prime minister um the kremlin has
named you today as their public enemy
number one um
saying you're the you're leading the
kind of anti-russian uh resistance uh
internationally i wonder
why you thought that had happened
whether you thought we were gonna get
any blow back
uh back home from that uh and how you
feel about it and you just mentioned uh
wind farms is the price of all this
going to be sort of going back to having
more onshore wind farms back home okay
well look at a couple of uh points there
jason first of all i think it's very
very important for everybody to
understand that i don't think there's a
single person around the table and in
nato
or the g7 uh who is against uh russians
or the russian people absolutely not
least of all me
i think i probably i'm i think i'm
probably the only prime minister in uk
history to be called boris uh you know i
i i have
i think i think i i have that
distinction uh
and
i'm not remotely anti-russian
but uh i think what we all agree is that
what
vladimir putin is doing the way he's
leading russia at the moment is utterly
catastrophic uh that his invasion of
ukraine is inhuman
and barbaric and the and the conduct of
that
invasion is now
moving into uh
the type of behavior that as i said
before we haven't seen in the continent
of europe for for 80 years uh and uh
it's horrific so you can be you can be
sympathetic towards uh ordinary russians
who are being so badly uh led uh but you
can be deeply hostile to uh the
decisions of vladimir putin the way he's
uh where he's leading his country uh
euro euro and you're sorry you had
another question about um
onshore wind uh look i i want to be
clear i think the the
massive opportunity for the uk is in
offshore wind and we've got good at that
uh we were until very recently i'm
slightly to my irritation we've seen it
been overtaken now by china but we were
until recently uh the biggest producer
of offshore wind in the world and one of
the things i want to be setting out in
the
forthcoming uh british energy security
strategy
is how we can uh regain our leaders the
number one and where we're going to be
doing it i think you can do it in a a
completely environmentally friendly way
you can generate phenomenal quantities
of renewable energy at zero marginal
cost and it's it's uh it is the it is
the way forward um euro news um
mcmahon
no no no euro news forgive me
um
i'm going to go to to natasha clark from
the sun
natasha jim stollenberg said earlier
today that there will be severe
consequences if russia does go ahead and
use chemical weapons in ukraine what
does that mean does it mean boots on the
ground or is that something we're
completely ruling out already um and you
said earlier that you'd like to see
ukraine handed to the hosting of the
next world cup would you like to see
them automatically qualify for this
year's world cup
uh right okay
uh so first of all on cb on chemical
biological uh tactical uh nuclear
weapons uh all of these are viewed with
utter horror by people around the table
uh today i i just heard uh from my my
friend uh fumio kishida who who
represents the only uh country in the g7
actually to have experienced uh nuclear
weapons on his or her seat had uh has
seen his country attacked uh by nuclear
weapons there is a visceral horror of
the use of these weapons of mass
destruction uh i think that if putin
were to
engage in anything like that uh the
consequences would be very very severe
you have to uh have a bit of ambiguity
about your
about your response but i think it would
be
catastrophic for him
if he were to do that and i i think that
he uh i think that he understands that
but you know when you look when you look
at what he's saying i think joe biden is
right uh to warn because you know when
when they when the russians start doing
this stuff
about
um oh well we've you know there are
factories in ukraine producing uh
american uh biological uh weaponry you
know that that is a prelude uh to a
false flag operation and they're gonna
uh they could well do something uh but i
think it would be a a profound and a
disastrous mistake for uh for putin
where he were he to do that on on
um ukraine qualifying for the
um
for the european is it the european i'm
not looking football is not is not my
best subject is you
the world cup you mean should they be
given a buy and and qualify
automatically
sounds like a good idea to me but i'm
i'm i'm out of area here i've got i've
got to admit that's not my strong
subject i don't i i don't see you i
don't see why not it might is my view um
james i'm not gonna listen
i'm not gonna comment on that james i'm
not gonna comment on that let's go to
but look let me put it put it this way
given what ukraine has been going
through uh given the the privations that
uh uh ukrainian footballers have had to
endure i'm sure that uh every possible
uh sympathy uh and allowances should be
made for them let me let me put it that
way how about that uh let's go to
natalia draws jack from bloomberg
yes
i just had two two quick questions uh on
the nuclear uh threat how concrete is
that can you give us a sense of those
discussions
um and secondly you mentioned this
morning
that
allies are examining ways to stop putin
from using russia's gold reserves can
you tell us whether those uh discussions
have moved on today thank you
yeah thanks uh natalia so uh
i think it's very important to stress
that i think that the discussion of the
use of nuclear weapons is is a
distraction and it's intended to be a
distraction
from what is really going on and that is
a savage attack uh with conventional uh
means on innocent people in urban
centers in ukraine absolutely barbaric
use of artillery and and uh mortars and
rockets as uh and as i've described
thermobaric bombs uh included it now
seems uh that is what is going on and
what we're talking about
uh is
the right of the ukrainian people to be
equipped
with the
weapons to defend themselves and all
discussion of nuclear weapons is
intended to to frame this as a as a
confrontation between russia as a
nuclear power and other nuclear powers
that's not what's going on what's going
on is a confrontation between russia an
entirely innocent uh people in ukraine
that's that's what it's between and what
we're trying to do is help
those people and i think that's in that
is morally uh the right thing to do on
on gold reserves
um
the
there is evidence that the russians may
be trying to get round i mean the
russians are obviously going to try to
get around the the sanctions on their on
their gold and uh we're taking steps to
try to make sure that there's no uh no
leakage or no sale of of bullion uh into
into markets around the world now and
and uh that's what we're working on uh
last question to steve swinford of the
times
prime minister just come back to
natasha's question uh we heard from a
nato uh
from a western official today um that if
russia did use chemical weapons uh in
ukraine it would be highly unlikely that
there would be a military intervention
from nato can i just clarify are you
in that position or would you rule that
out or do you think it's possible that
we could have a military intervention is
it is it something you're prepared to
consider i i just want to to repeat the
answer i gave to natasha which is i
think that uh any such action would be
not only uh uh
morally repugnant in indefensible uh but
disastrous for uh for putin as well uh
and i i think well i'm afraid i'm gonna
have to to leave it there and rush for
the plane under the strict instructions
thank you all very much thank you thank
you
so the prime minister boris johnson
there holding a news conference in
brussels after his nato and g7 meetings
with his allies his main message that he
announced at the beginning was that
ukraine was not alone he's just coming
back okay
he remembers me
yes so
now you have i'm gonna regret this by
the way that's what you had you had
talked with uh mr erdogan and you
both uh um
the most friends of ukraine
and ukrainians hope
on you on great britain
and turkey
and you told that you can provide
more
armament
for ukraine but you didn't say
about
air defense
weapons yes it's the main
what what is necessary for ukraine how
it to arrange because you see
the
some of for instance your colleague from
france mr macron told that no we don't
want to provide something because we
don't to be part of the war
well thank you very much so
uh as you know the
uh
i think one of the most significant uh
contributions that uh turkey is
currently making uh are the tb2s uh
which i think are
very valuable uh what the uh what the uk
is is providing as i'm sure you've also
seen uh our air defenses and and we're
helping the uh the ukrainians to
understand how to uh to to use them i
think that's entirely uh that's entirely
reasonable but i don't i think i should
really go beyond uh beyond what i said
uh what i like
the general
tenor of the meeting what everybody
wants to do is make sure uh that as as
putin
ramps it up as putin escalates his
aggression that we do ever more to
defend and protect uh the ukrainians and
that's what we're gonna do thank you all
very much thank you thank you
so boris johnson leaving for a second
time from that news conference persuaded
to return for just one more question
his message as i was saying to ukraine
was that the country was not alone he
said we stand with the people of kiev
mario paul and donetsk
the people of ukraine must prevail and
putin must fail and he talked about the
discussions he'd had during the day with
his allies of the g7 and nato
saying that those discussions had
allowed them talked about ramping up
lethal aid he said of the quality and
quantity
that ukraine would need to defend itself
from
its bullying neighbor and asked by our
political correspondent sam coates about
whether that included the tanks and the
jets that president zielenski of ukraine
had explicitly asked for today he said
logistically that was difficult at the
moment and he said they were providing
the kind of equipment that he felt that
was most valuable to them missiles to
protect from the air and from russian
heavy military and uh he pointed out
that they had indeed britain made a
an announcement in fact it was last
night ahead of this meeting of a package
of 6000 more missiles as well as a
package of sanctions he was asked about
europe weaning itself off oil and gas
and said that they were all doing their
part it was difficult some countries
would find it more difficult than others
but they were all doing their best there
and he was also asked about the
discussion around nuclear weapons and he
said it was important to stress that
discussion of the use of nuclear weapons
is a distraction he said it was a
distraction
from the barbaric use of artillery by
putin on civilians
so boris johnson there the prime
minister of holding that news conference
at the end of his day
there in brussels eu meetings continue
though
meanwhile nato has said that the
military alliance is stepping up its
defenses in the event of a chemical or
nuclear attack by russia
our top military commander general
walters has activated nato's chemical
biological
radiological and nuclear
defense elements
and allies are deploying additional
chemical and biological and nuclear
defenses to reinforce our existing and
new backing groups
well in ukraine itself there are signs
that the ukrainian military is beginning
a counter-offensive
nato estimates that between seven and
fifteen thousand russian troops have
been killed in the last month
the un says at least
1035 people have been killed in a month
of war in ukraine including 90 children
and further uk sanctions have been
announced on 65 russian businesses and
individuals including the stepdaughter
of the russian foreign minister sergey
lavrov who lives in london
well the ukrainian military says it's
destroyed a large russian paratroop ship
in the southern port city of birdiansk
sky news has located and verified this
video the deputy defense minister says
the ship can carry up to 20 tanks 45
armoured personnel carriers and 400
paratroopers
well our correspondent sally lockwood is
in la viv in uh western ukraine for us
now so sally we heard from the prime
minister in the last few minutes at the
end of his day after meetings with nato
and the g7 do you think what's been
agreed there is likely to be enough for
president zielinski who appealed to
leaders in english today
yeah ukraine is desperate for more
western support they're fast running out
of weapons and ammunition president
zielenski has called for all manner of
things when it comes to extra support
and certainly what nato's offered today
has been welcomed here in ukraine but
those high-end talks in brussels which
uh
you know
due to help people here in ukraine the
44 million people that are so uh
traumatized by the last month of war a
quarter of the population now displaced
certainly they're desperate for that
help but many of them don't have the
luxury of following those diplomatic uh
developments
and some of the most desperate people in
the country well they simply can't be
heard anymore that city in
the south of the country mario pole
which has been bombed for weeks now uh
well that has been without power without
food and medical supplies without
internet and phone signal for weeks and
we've just received uh some rather stark
new drone images uh from mario poll
which is as about as close as we can get
to the city
just showing a huge line of people
waiting for humanitarian
aid in a city that has been largely
destroyed by bombing both day and night
for weeks now now uh attacks from the
air remain
one of the primary concerns here the
ground offensives have
largely stalled and failed in some areas
of the country but the uh air assault
certainly uh mario paul is the most dark
example of that and it's fast becoming
one of the biggest humanitarian
disasters of modern times the bombings
they're already labeled war crimes but
president zielenski also raised the
other great concern for ukraine now
which is the possible use of chemical
weapons uh here in the country citing uh
examples that he says are of phosphorus
bombs being used here in ukraine now we
haven't managed to verify that news but
there have been two examples of that uh
one just outside kiev and one in the
eastern region of lugansk certainly that
remains the very concerning
potential threat now from russia the use
of chemical weapons which of course is
indeed a red line uh it's against the
geneva convention uh it would be seen as
a war crime and certainly there would be
pressure on nato to respond but
certainly a sense of confidence in
ukraine that they will they will get
through this uh just at what cost sally
there in la vie in ukraine thanks very
much indeed
so let's go back now to brussels and
bring in our deputy political editor sam
coats who was in that boris johnson news
conference so sam we heard you asking a
question there
tell us about that and what you made of
what the prime minister said
well all day in brussels here we've had
world leaders talking about their
commitment and their unity when it comes
to standing by ukraine but really we got
down to brass tacks in that press
conference with boris johnson and that's
where some of the divisions some of the
problems actually became pretty stark
president zelinski did something
important today he dropped his request
he didn't make his requests he's made
before for a no-fly zone instead he
asked for something very very specific
he asked for more jets and more tanks
i asked boris johnson did he get them
today and the answer appears to be no
you could see just how conflicted boris
johnson was about this he said president
zlenski needs tanks to try and free up
people in mario pool but he said it's
very difficult logistically to do that
and very difficult to provide jets nato
concentrating on defensive rather than
offensive weapons and that looks like a
line they haven't agreed to cross today
fearing that that could drag everybody
into some kind of much bigger conflict
instead boris johnson told the room that
there are other types of missiles again
defensive missiles that might be more
useful to president zelinski the
president of ukraine had just told nato
leaders what he needed it sounded like
he's not going to get it
okay sam i think you've got a rush to
catch your plane so we'll let you go
thanks very much indeed
and just to let you know that we are
expecting to hear from the u.s president
joe biden who's due to show up uh for
the meeting of eu leaders uh also in
brussels a little bit later so as soon
as he arrives we'll of course
cover that for you
now the trial of the man accused of
murdering the mp sir david amos has been
shown dramatic body cam footage of his
attacker being tackled by police
ali habi ali is heard being told to